the growing popularity of online
shopping is changing the retail business
and affecting everything from shopping
malls to the shipping industry it also
means that items are returned in greater
numbers than ever before
this morning we're taking a close look
at where do those returns go after you
send them back Janet shamlian is in
Houston Texas to show us why if you
returned too much you could get
blacklisted Janet good morning Gail good
morning to you stores like Best Buy
moved tons of electronics out the door
but you might be surprised at how much
of it comes back in in fact for online
sellers the return rate is as high as
30% it's all created a massive secondary
market and now some stores are watching
you more closely than you might think
welcome to the land of buyer's remorse
towers of toys mountains of merchandise
this Texas warehouse is the size of two
football fields and just about
everything in it is something someone
change their mind about 400 truckloads a
week bikes large appliances clothing and
electronics similar items like cell
phone cases and chargers are boxed
together and sold as a lot all of it
then goes up for sale or auction online
sites like liquidation calm and second
dippity calm every box we open or every
pallet we open you never know what's
going to be in it
brian johnson of liquidity services a
major player in the almost four hundred
billion dollar business of flipping
returns like these rows of ipads being
wiped of personal information and
readied for resale why don't the
retailers resell it themselves a lot of
it is box damaged and so if you go in
and you want to pay full price at a
retailer you want it in pristine
condition
and handling returns themselves cuts
into a stores profits free shipping and
liberal return policies have made it
easy to get a refund for almost anything
11 percent of all purchases are returned
many stores track how much merchandise a
customer returns sometimes denying
future returns based on their history
there should be no secret databases
customers should be aware of everybody
collecting information consumer
advocates like ed Knorr insky are
concern that data is increasingly being
shared among retailers creating a
database of serial returners I encourage
any consumer who's been denied the right
to return a product because some
database they didn't know about said to
the company
don't let him return that product you
should complain to the Federal Trade
Commission Best Buy discloses its
tracking policy in fine print on the
customer's receipt some stores don't
this time of year the warehouse
overflows with one item in particular
big-screen televisions in fact they
start flooding in right after the
Superbowl and it continues for several
weeks many people buy them specifically
to watch the game and then return them
immediately after Raphael guy time what
25 of the returned TVs as he does almost
every week a few like this is 75 inches
for about 650
600 or 650 from here you buy it and you
can sell it for $1,000 like many of the
buyers here flipping it for a profit is
his full-time job everybody's always
looking for this and the business of
customer returns as the marketplace
allows fickle shoppers the chance to
change their minds so how do you know if
you've returned too much well short of
buying 10 pair of shoes and returning 9
you probably won't until you go to take
something back and that return is
refused at the store the so called
wardrobing of items like you saw with
the tvs buying it using a taking it back
is a growing problem for the industry
those items are resold but it's just
pennies on the dollar
bianna well I have to say Janet that's
the first time I heard about flipping
television especially around the
Superbowl thank you that was a real
Texas night the warehouse - right yeah I
often buy the two sizes like a 10 and a
12 and then return one I guess they
don't like you to do that are they
giving you more of a hassle these days
no maybe after today